one of the things uh jim jeffries
besides being really funny and a great
stand-up you uh
you get away with saying [ __ ] more than
anybody i know i do i i brought [ __ ] to
america i believe you brought me yeah i
think i think columbus found the actual
country and then you did the [ __ ] just a
[ __ ] without the tree i feel like i
freed everyone up when i first got here
that was the one rule uh you know 15
years ago that was the rule you can say
what you want don't say [ __ ] that was
the big thing who said that to you every
comedy club i went to that was that was
but they just that was hello jim don't
say [ __ ] it was further on in the
conversation i'm paraphrasing of course
but but they they would say don't say
[ __ ] and then i'd go on and say it and
then they they're no problem because of
the accent and uh you think it's the
accent i do believe it's the accent yeah
because you can say it in australia you
can say but even more in the uk than you
can in australia so
all the comics in the uk when i started
out they were all saying it i'll tell
you
my best [ __ ] story um
let's let's uh lead into so this is the
best [ __ ] store you have well it's not
the funniest but it's it's the most app
i think okay so i i uh i did an hbo
special maybe 13 years ago and when i
did the hbo special they sort of picked
out of all my material or material they
wanted me to do et cetera like this is
my first american special and uh hbo
said to me they said the the one thing
about americans they don't like the c
word
uh and we want to have retention they're
big on like uh people still watching
after 15 minutes you know what i mean it
doesn't matter what your ratings are
they're still watching
so i had uh no [ __ ] for the first 15
minutes no [ __ ] for 15 minutes i counted
50. is that tough for you it was it was
okay i practiced right but there was
there was there was a [ __ ] light at the
back of the room a what i [ __ ] like we
didn't say the word [ __ ] in big letters
but it it flashed when i was allowed to
start saying it when 15 minutes hit you
you got a [ __ ] like hbo got me a [ __ ]
like it's a it's a flash on like you can
say it now and i think the fact that
there is somebody on that was hired by
hbo for 15 minutes looking at their
watch
going and and they're the jim jeffries
[ __ ] timer yes yeah because normally us
comics so we have a light to say we have
10 minutes left five minutes left two
minutes left whatever we request i had a
15 minute light to say that i was about
to say and i think the first one i
dropped on american tv was aunt panda's
a bunch of [ __ ]
and why did you say that again aunt
panda's a bunch of [ __ ] and i did a
routine on pandas
yeah i love how you were able to blend
like pandas these soft fuzzy
cuddly things with [ __ ]
this is what i think about the word
right it's it's in other cultures
because here in america it seems to have
it's directed at women and it's a
nastier type of term where in britain
especially somewhere like ireland
um
it's can be said affectionately you know
affectionately yeah you guys a little
contact one ah look at this little [ __ ]
over here for your children yeah yeah i
got cool much than that all the time all
right your son you call a [ __ ] yeah but
in a nice way nice way i you know it's
like yeah just affectionately and you
call your wife a [ __ ] ah my wife's
british so yeah we can say that to each
other and she she says like she melts
when you color doesn't melt when we do
it we're allowed to say it it's it's all
right but uh you can't say you can say
the word [ __ ] with affection you go my
mate he's a good [ __ ] that fellow this
guy's a good kind i like that [ __ ] right
i like that [ __ ] yeah we can say that in
america too but not yeah i feel like we
should have a [ __ ] timer yeah and
there's a podcast it's already uh
my my argument is it's less offensive
than the word [ __ ] the word [ __ ] can
never be said kindly and you you guys
say that word a lot i don't say that
word very much at all americans say the
word [ __ ] quite often you think a [ __ ]
is worse than a [ __ ] you can i can go
that council right you got to meet this
[ __ ] he's a good [ __ ] right yeah but i
can never go
gotta meet this [ __ ] she's a good [ __ ]
you're right why not yeah you can it
sounds no
mean no
no i beg to differ maybe with your
accent i can't say [ __ ] i sound
stupid when i say it i can't say it so
you can just say [ __ ] and it's
acceptable with your ass yeah then i
should we just make phone calls and call
people and if a female answers let's see
if you can get away with calling her a
[ __ ] i think i'd be all right i think
really yeah
i'm pretty confident let's call it call
mom
come on i'm going to call oh we're not
calling that cat are we yeah
i'm going to call i'm going to call my
wife what but how do i work it into it
you got to get me some type of script i
can't why no no i can't just i gave you
a script i gave you one word hello miss
matt mrs mandel you can't i can't do
that that's too hard well you're the
expert i don't use the word i i've i've
called myself out here i said i can do
it now i'm not so sure
hello hello
hi how are you doing you [ __ ] it's uh
jim jeffries
oh hi how you doing good thank you thank
you i think that proved our point
did you not hear what he said no
what he said hi it's jim jeffries here
yes
he referred to you
what did he call me a punch yes
yeah well you know what
if the shoe fits
that's how big she is you cannot put an
entire shoe in there
i love you i think you're so talented
and funny oh thank you thank you you're
welcome you're a great counter i really
appreciate that bye bye my little [ __ ]
see you if i can see you later bye bye
your mother your mother is such a gun
she's fun lady man she's a fun country
[Music]